well let's let's let's talk about the
next uh ultra work story here so uh this
is something that's been going viral
quite a bit
we got this from newsweek coca-cola
facing backlash says
be less white learning plan was about
workplace
inclusion that's the gist of the story
coca-cola is facing a mounting backlash
from conservatives
online that's what i really love about
how they frame this conservatives are
upset
ian are you a conservative well not not
really sometimes
do you think it's absurd that coca-cola
told his employees to be less white yeah
it's ridiculous
so newsweek you need to correct your
story it's not concerned it's not just
it actually says that be less white try
to be
less white that's ridiculous if i heard
that i was okay i'd be like darken my
skin
like with a crayon that's that's that's
what i was saying like first like i
thought
you know like putting on bronzer and
stuff was racist it's literally a slide
that says try to be less white oh man
and the way that
they they describe white is oppressive
arrogant and ignorant
now if you said be less oppressive
arrogant and ignorant that's all you
know
no they're saying if you're white you
are bringing you are
oppressive arrogant and ignorant and i i
have to point out um
you know luke and i are both not white
yep oh no i'm sorry i'm sorry that's
wrong i'm double handleless you're
you're like triple white no no no no
no no not anymore not anymore according
to who the protesters in new york
so the asians were getting attacked and
they said march against white
nationalism
and that proves that asians are now
minorities again
oh all right but lucas slavic and
according to the coalition of people of
the coalition of communities i'm looking
it up right now so i can get my card i'm
getting my privilege card ready
there's there's an organization called
the it's called the coalition of
communities of color and they say slavic
people are not white
so for luke here who's literally got you
know what
what color is your hair look you say
strawberry blonde brown yeah yeah
strawberry blue dirty blonde blue eyes
yeah white skin
big nose you're not white and looking
like
[Laughter]
you're not white that so try be more
like luke apparently coke is saying
yeah i don't understand this so you're
not considered white i wasn't i was born
in poland
so being born in poland i'm a slavic
individual victims of communism
i think you're literally like taylor
than i am and i'm
paying you i make an observation like
this i am pink
okay no you're beige beige better yeah
okay
this is what they're trying to say
though they're saying it's like
politically white
well this is a thing they make this
distinction this is the weirdest thing
about liberals today i just
this stuff kills me they make this
distinction between white people and
whiteness
all the time as if it somehow makes what
they're saying less racist
like it's this thing that they're like
you know what i mean like on a
fundamental level
being a white person is okay but having
a whiteness this internalized thing that
you can have as just any person not okay
and it's like
yep all right cool makes sense it's it's
it's so insidious how they
they tie negative traits towards the
idea of being white
and then when you call them for racist
they go oh no no we don't mean your race
we mean it's just a word and you're like
no but if no one understands that you're
literally talking about race
my favorite thing with the story there's
a couple articles one of them
said it said coca-cola is accused of
reverse racism
for saying try to be less white i
haven't heard anybody say that's reverse
racist
everyone's just saying it's literally
racist another thing that's really
important to kind of point out here you
brought up the rally that happened in
new york city where hundreds of people
came out
against the rally against white
nationalism for
noel quintano noel contano was a
filipino man that was slashed across the
face beat up
brutally not by a white guy
and it was a people were saying this was
a racially motivated
motivated attack it's all because of
white nationalism the guy who attacked
him wasn't white
was he was he black yeah same in same in
san francisco there's another
uh you know report of a hate crime and
there's another call for a rally against
white nationalism and again
the victim was asian and the perpetrator
was
not white this is this is the biggest
problem i have with it
first i i just need to clarify so i'm uh
i'm once again not white is that what's
happening here
well you're like you're like you know
you have a lot of privilege so you're
getting kicked out of universities
uh that's true so because you're too
smart yeah
yeah well so the problem i have is these
well-to-do
liberal progressive types are tar
are focusing on some racial ideology
that literally
nothing to do with these crimes making
it harder for us to actually have
activism around these crimes
i don't care if the perpetrator was
white or black or asian or latino i care
that the crime that was committed was
illegal and someone got hurt
so how about we rally against violence
we rally against
racially motivated violence they make it
about white nationalism
and then there's no real conversation
about what's driving the racism in these
communities
the problem is if they acknowledge that
guess what black people can be racist
asian people
asian people are really racist
particularly in asia i
i'm not super you know i know a lot of a
lot of american
asian people as well who are pretty good
because americans
we grew up in this culture we tend to do
a better job but my friends
and people i know who have come from
asian countries
they tend to be pretty racist right
anybody of any race can be racist have
prejudicial views
and view others as superior or inferior
it is rampant
in southeast asia no joke and if we
can't get
acknowledge that because these
well-to-do white progressives are
obsessed with themselves
and they think somehow white is superior
or privileged
like i'm sorry man that is leftist white
supremacy
that this idea that their race is is
paramount and privileged above all
others
and that no matter what happens no
matter who commits the crime it's not
the
fault of the individual commit the crime
it's white
like these people really hold themselves
to such a steam
that no matter it's it's remarkable no
matter who commits the crime they're
like well actually it's all about white
people
i'm like dude you're racist that's not
true man
and actually you know traveling the
world whether it was asia africa latin
america
you realize that holy cow the world's
really racist and
i'll just be honest here you know i'm
not a big nationalist at all i don't i
don't like governments at all but
the united states honestly is one of the
least racist places that i've
you know seen and and was able to
observe it is the least racist place
i've ever been to
yeah same no joke yeah you traveled to
africa you travel to asia you travel to
latin america your eyes will
open up into the reality of the world
sweden sweden is more was more racist
than the united states when i went there
it was shockingly racist but maybe
racist isn't necessarily the
right word xenophobic is probably a
better word for it and i know that word
gets thrown around a lot by progressives
in this country but no let me explain
we interviewed this woman who was
american who spoke swedish
got married to a swede moved to sweden
and she couldn't get a job
and she said it's because nobody wants
to hire someone with an accent
so it wasn't even about the race it was
about you're not swedish
so it's super nationalistic in a sense
and what i discovered especially in
sweden especially from many minorities
who are working and trying to end the
stuff they would say like
swedes very much like to pretend that
they're not racist
but they are super racist so what
they'll do is they'll be like we're
going to help all these poor minorities
and then put them all into like some
community with limited resources and do
nothing for them
and watch it fester and then just claim
to everybody how not racist they are
super racist the people pretending not
to be racist are usually the biggest
racist
same with uh homophobes the biggest
homophobes are usually
the biggest guys who are in the closet
let's just be honest what was up with
all those republicans
who were like super anti-gay but then
turned out to be gay yeah that that
republican who was caught in the
bathroom
all right all right trying to solicit
from an undercover
police officer or something activity i'm
family friendly don't worry tim i'm
gonna be very family friendly here
another thing to really kind of consider
here is that
you know a lot of people are attributing
you know white nationalism to
you know different people of race you
know beating each other up but
this is happening in new york city this
is happening in san francisco where
we're seeing these rallies and we're
seeing these kind of alleged hate crimes
but we have to understand
crime is going up dramatically in these
places regardless of race it's becoming
more of a violent
more of a criminal place where even a
two-year-old got punched in the head by
a panhandler
in a new york city subway just recently
there was other footage of a guy beating
another one with a baseball bat brutally
the amount of violence that is
overtaking new york city is really
reaching proportions that are unlivable
for many people it's one of the reasons
i left i'm never going to be coming back
there ever again and this is the city
that i grew up in this is the city that
i was raised in
and it's even coming back to a place
where when i first came into it it was
extremely violent extremely
somewhere who you don't want to be so
let's we'll bring it back to this
coca-cola thing where they're telling
people to be less white
this weird try to be less white thing is
the result
of people who refuse to acknowledge the
problems in their community and look for
a scapegoat
if if there is an asian man who is
slashed across the face
attacked by a black person race doesn't
need to be
the defining like the law was broken you
can't slash people in the face
what happens then is you get these
activists these progressives
scapegoating the problem
making it about white nationalism
instead of general crime
violence poverty etc so the problem
doesn't get solved
and then people who don't understand
what the march is all about
instead of going after the core issues
class issues for one
they then start saying we need to tell
everybody to be less white because you
see what happens to that poor asian man
i'm like that had nothing to do with it
now also you got coca-cola they don't
know what that means be less white they
have no idea what it is they read it in
the robin d'angelo book
that woman is an avowed racist she says
she's a racist
why are you teaching people to be like a
racist woman it makes no sense
it's it's funny because like when you
when you talk about this as someone
who's grown up in a different country
like that's australia and obviously
australia's pretty ethno-homogenous in
the sense that you know i think the
population is 90
wide or something like that you have
this perception of the u.s when you come
here and then when you see what the
communities are like i agree with you in
the sense that there's a lot of
non-self-accountability that goes down
in particular communities
that it and as someone who has now lived
in the us for almost two years who's
observed a lot of it as a completely
objective third-party observer i have no
personal interest in
like the the racial affairs of the
united states but when i watch this
stuff
and when you are treated by in a certain
way by particular groups of people you
come to realize that it's not
the white population in my opinion maybe
i'm saying this because i'm a white
person that's probably what people would
say but
as a white person i don't think that
it's the white population that's even
the racist group in this country
i don't know if i don't know if you guys
would agree with that but as an outsider
someone who's come into it i think that
there's a lot of
i think you're wrong you think the white
population is the most racist
absolutely all the time all they're
called liberals yeah they're called
they're called democrats
no but generally like white like even i
know you guys are joking below no no no
no
no no no no no white liberals are yeah
for sure but like normal people you and
me i don't i don't care what you look
like just be normal to me
right right listen listen i i think i
understand what you're trying to say
that you're you're you're talking about
like negative racism where
someone would attack a person of another
race right no i'm talking about the fact
that like
america so i don't see white people
going around and going you know what we
should do we should put anyone who's not
white in internment camps
see that's one aspect of racism when you
have a bunch of white people saying
white is bad so there's a chart that
shows
in group out out-group preference among
different races and
uh they split up white by liberal and
conservative
liberals are the only group with an
out-group preference
white liberals are quite literally the
most racist
so the in-group preference among black
asian
you know latino is less i believe
than the out-group preference of white
liberals but i don't
consider their opinions when i talk
about anything because i think they're
so radical and
like i really do i think they're so
radical that i don't i don't even
register
the far left to me these these the
people that you're talking about
to me they're so far gone that they i
don't even register this
this is major companies these these are
the establishment pushing these talking
points we're talking about
governments universities high schools
major corporations pushing
these talking points these lectures by
robin d'angelo this this
white woman who's trying to make sure
people don't understand that she's also
white
uh she's racist she says she's racist
yes it's when do we take our talking
points from racism coca-cola employs a
large number of employees and this
influence this kind of uh you know
conjecture of how bad it is to be white
how bad it is to be born of a certain
dna you know assembly
it's just absolutely ridiculous but this
is the institutions that
set policies these are young minds of
children that are being taught
this in in schools every single day this
is going to become the new norm
this kind of line of thinking if it's
not challenged and it's not challenged
it's coming back under the biden
presidency and it's going to be
institutionalized
so much to the point where this is the
new normal it already is
institutionalized
i mean literally like the newest video
that i made i literally just posted this
yesterday
is about like i have a series white
people bad and it's basically just where
i find the most
ridiculous things on the internet of
people um
i'm trying not to swear to him i'm
trying to think of words people just
attacking white people over just
nonsense and there was one thing that i
found that
really disturbed me and it came from i
believe the original post was basically
white people can experience murder
and i and i went and looked into that
yeah it was mental i went and looked at
it
i looked into it a little bit and i
believe that it's more or less a troll
post came from like 4chan you know where
they want to like roll people up
because i couldn't find it on any lefty
forums but when i read it i was like
this sounds like saying a regressive
leftist would say
but that's that was not the disturbing
part the disturbing thing
was a video that i found that had been
um screened effectively at a
university so to speak in san francisco
called why don't we murder
more white people what what
yes what yep no no it's i like i
encourage people i'm not going to float
my own channel but
i put a bunch of clips in this video
shut it up um
no it's just i mean like i just it was
the name of the video
the video on my channel that you did
about this white people bad part three
okay
that's an easy title so let's listen
it's literally the noise viewer but this
thing was mental i
my gosh uh uh the area i grew up in was
very was very just
mixed a bunch of different you know with
polish immigrants we had latino we had
asian we had black people
and we all got along with each other and
i think it was because we all live next
to each other you know what i mean
when when you say do you don't think
white people are the most racist
i would say if you have this view of
racism as like a guy walks into a store
and they say we don't serve your kind
round these parts
but we're talking about understanding
literal racism the white progressives in
this country
are substantially exponentially more
racist than any other group i've ever
encountered
i i've i've been all over the country
been all over the planet and it was it
was amazing when i first went to occupy
wall street so i had before i could buy
water i hadn't left
the country but i had been all over the
country in various places i had been in
conservative areas i've been on a
military basis
i got to you know i hung out with people
who are religious and pro-life
and i really didn't think racism was all
that
prominent i thought like this is it like
we've done away with these old
stereotypes
there's still problems you know the
remnants of blockbusting and redlining
persisted into the 80s and still exist
in some forms today
but i'm like man we really are winning
and crushing these these racists
and then i went to occupy wall street
and the progressives
segregated everybody based on race into
different groups
based on their race and your voting
privileges in the community was
determined
partially based on your race so they had
some groups where was like the black
caucus got a vote and how money was
spent simply because it was a group of
black people but then you had like the
sanitation working group
they got a vote on spending money based
on the fact that they all cleaned and
were sanitary
and so i was like i don't understand why
voting power is derived based on the
fact that you're a group of people based
on race
and they were like you just don't
understand because you know we got to
just you know break down all the racism
whatever
there was one black dude at occupy wall
street not super involved and he was
chilling i saw him arguing with somebody
one day that's not a ducati park
and i overheard him talking and then he
was disparaging occupy wall street
is interesting so i went to when i was
like i was like hey bro you're hanging
out here you think this is crazy
and he went bro do you have any idea
what the press would say if they found
out y'all are segregating people based
on race into different colored groups
that's crazy
and i was like i agree with you these
people are nuts i had never experienced
a kind of racism in my life
i have i have met racist redneck
conservative types
and i have heard them say horrible
things but it's it's always like
so i had an uber driver once who was
like it was in virginia
and this guy was super racist he slowly
started
we were talking about politics and then
he mentioned something particularly
racist and then immediately walked it
back
because he knew it was not socially
acceptable so that guy was a racist
but he couldn't say it these
progressives flaunt it they they shout
to the high heavens we're racist they
scream and then write books about it and
coca-cola hires them to teach their
employees how to be racist
welcome to america 2021 it's insane one
of the other interesting aspects of
occupy
wall street being there from the very
beginning to the very end was to see it
kind of emerge into two different
classes
we had the we had the uptown area which
which had all the
liberals and all the white people in the
libraries and then we had the downtown
area
and then the uptown and the downtown
area had an internal conflict and fight
within occupy wall street so seeing
these social dynamics kind of recreate
and
recreate itself in our main society was
amazing
and incredible to see in real life as it
kind of unfolded on this kind of time
scale but
another thing i wanted to bring up
babylon b made some really good points
today
and they brought up seven points about
how to be less white uh if you don't
mind i'm gonna read some of them i'm not
gonna read all of them but i think
there's some important takeaways here
number five it says throw away all of
your ranch dressing
ranch dressing mayo it's all gotta go no
i love mayo number seven it says hate
yourself
every walking moment until you have
sufficiently atoned to your whiteness
oops spoiler alert you'll never
sufficiently atone for your whiteness
better go back to step three step three
step three is to you know
terminate yourself terminate functions
yeah terminate your internal functions
from uh working as a human being
and then and then there you go racism
ended forever so babylon be uh pretty
interesting
you say it is particular you say rip off
your skin but you you like that's what's
what's
weird is they're making a joke but did
you guys see that cut video that came
out like three months ago that talked
about like all the
reasons white people are the worst in
the world like what are white people
superior at did you guys see that
no okay i'm surprised that you didn't
because this this viewer basically see
it
yeah i'm sure i'm sure you guys did like
basically it was it was a group of um
they collected a hundred black folks
with an ex
love that for them and got them in a
room and said what are white people
superior at and it starts off like real
light-hearted like haha mayonnaise like
okay
white people love they dogs at one bit
and then it goes into oh they're better
at oppression they're better at white
supremacy they're better at murder
they're better
it's so not true because i got to be
honest asians are just so much better at
a lot of these things
japanese mongolia would like to speak to
you japan
japan wants to have a conversation guys
japan has a lot to say about this
i found out that i was i always i always
thought i was a quarter korean
and then i found i'm actually five
percent japanese through dna tests
and then i was like you know why that
happened
no but i mean this is things like you
make jokes about it but then you go and
watch this content that mind you is
still up on youtube doesn't break any
freaking guidelines and things
that has people literally saying that
white people are the best at oppression
okay well thank you well what uh let's
let's say good things
uh what what what what uh are white
people good at
um tan no
figure skating is that true no no
country dancing yeah square yes yes
square dancing yep
uh capitalism yes it even feels dirty to
say it i don't know
he's like i don't know but no one's
white
it's such a weird phrase they're wailing
actually no it's not even true japanese
way better what the heck
dna is better let me let me tell you
about skateboarding stereotypes
i'll tell you about skateboarding types
right these are stereotypes that i'm not
saying are true
but were brought up to me when i was
young in skateboarding
asian skateboarders tend to be good at
technical skateboarding which means
they can do extremely complicated
maneuvers so it's like combining the
most tricks into one trick
uh black skateboarders tend to and again
this is a stereotype that this game you
know people in skateboarding have said
tend to be able to ollie better than
anybody and and do some of like the best
flat ground skating
and then white people are really good at
jumping off buildings
joke no joke these are the stereotypes
so like
this is this again i'm not saying i
agree with them or even support these
ideas but these are stereotypes that
emerge
so when people joke i'll tell you this
too
want to hear racism but that no one
cares about
go to a skate park and you'll hear the
n-word more more times than you've ever
heard in your life
and nobody cares it's all just like
urban culture i get you get people of
all different races saying it over and
over again
so these are stereotypes that get
brought up and so what typically what's
what people will say is like when they
talk about you know what are white
people good at it's like man they can
jump off buildings and jump down
railings
basically and this does align kind of
with conquest and oppression in my
opinion
war you know world war europe a lot of
conflict and i was reading about this
and they and i was reading that was
because population density in europe
with nowhere to go
whereas in north america asia and africa
you actually can flee
in the event of conflict in crisis in
europe they couldn't so those who
survived were those willing to fight
more
you know that makes sense i don't know
that's true though you know but it does
fall in like kind of what they were
saying about oppression or whatever
well i mean like i guess that some of
the biggest empires were what roman
greek i don't know the uh
the spanish the french but who are the
biggest because then if we really want i
mean like
english the english empire was what that
took over like 40
genghis khan as well he was he was
pretty dope man he was
not so much but he i watched marco polo
recently that that
show honestly he was pretty good i
learned some stuff apparently it's
changus not
genghis so i've been saying it wrong my
whole life wait it's chengiskan it's
like big changes
apparently it's a c c sound rather than
a g sound so i've been
saying that wrong i heard he enforced
civil rights
yeah he did he was a weird one because
he even though he took over so much land
it was
almost like what the romans did where
the romans went in and were like okay
this is
ours now you can still do your own thing
but we're still going to tax you and
whatever but you can stay here and do
whatever but
what i figured out what my people are
good at what communism oh yeah
wait no no they're not good at it they
failed every time everyone did
everything but but 100 percent of the
time but karl marx invented it
or like he didn't invent it he like kind
of wrote about it with his friends now
there was a racist
oh my goodness if you look at his
letters oh my
yeah don't i don't isn't it weird that
all these people that like
white liberals uphold to this standard
are honestly some of the worst humans
when it comes to the treatment of other
racial groups yeah
chekavara uh mao zeitong yeah
so you know listening to the beatles you
have uh the song revolution
and he has that line when i was a little
kid i did not understand what this meant
but if you go carrying pictures of
chairman mao
you ain't gonna make it make it with
anyone anyhow apparently you will i was
a little kid i didn't understand what
that meant
i was just like huh chairman yeah like
you know and i was like a little kid
singing beatles and like you know
running around playing guitar whatever
and then i got older and i was like oh i
get it he was saying yo
don't support authoritarian communists
bro like that's pretty legit
yeah and uh i don't know maybe his
message didn't work out all that well
yeah well obviously it didn't yeah
because these people are all about it
yep yeah yeah they wanna they wanna turn
america into what like a socialist
utopia i'm excited
i can't wait to be like standing in my
bread line you know getting like
besieged oh my god i can't wait so
excited i'm stoked yeah
it's gonna be great yeah my family
doesn't have good reviews no
communism from what they went through
how many stars how many stars
uh zero there's no stars in communism
there's only one redistribution of stars
for everyone
everyone gets a star everybody gets one
one
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you